MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section and
also the next one,
we're going to make a
case against aether.
Aether was presumed to be the
medium in which light traveled.
We do this-- we make
this case by studying
the Michelson-Morley experiment.
Michelson and Morley
went out to detect
the motion of the Earth
relative to aether.
And by not finding
the result, we
can conclude that, at
least in this form,
aether doesn't exist.
So what is the
experimental setup?
Also, it's shown in
the pictures above.
We have a light source
here, through which
the light travel to
some mirror which
reflects about half the light.
About half the light
goes through reflected
on the second mirror and
then comes to a screen.
The other part of the
light is up and back down.
So the light either travels
against the aether wind
or perpendicular
to the aether wind.
If aether is the medium
in which light travels,
then the velocity
needs to change.
The velocity of light in
this medium will change.
If there is no
aether wind, there
is no change in the
velocity of the light.
The result of the experiment
is an interference pattern
on the screen.
The experiment is called
an interferometer.
So there are some systematic
uncertainties here.
There are some unknowns.
For example, if you're
building your table,
it's not really clear in which
direction aether actually--
which direction is actually the
direction of the aether flow.
But you can get by this
by rotating the table
and making various
sets of experiments.
And that's what
Michelson and Morley did.
I want you to show
that the effect they're
about to observe--
or they will not observe--
is of the order of
v over c squared.
And what you want
to do is compare
the light as it travels on this
path number 1 to one mirror
and on the second path
to the second mirror.
So if you're
following the video,
I ask you to just stop here
and figure out how long does it
take for the light to
travel on this path
here-- on the lower path, path
number 1, or path number 2.
Well, obviously, I've
worked this out already.
So we want to
calculate the time it
takes light to
travel path 1 that
is going up and coming down--
going left and going right.
So in the first
case, the velocity
is reduced by the
velocity of aether.
So the time it takes
is l1, the leg,
divided by c minus v plus the
return leg, l1 over c plus v.
And you work this out, and
you simplify a little bit,
you get this first equation.
For the second part,
the one up and down,
you want to draw
this triangle here
to figure out that t
is equal-- the time
it takes is equal to the
square root of l square
over c square minus v square.
And then you simplify again,
you get this [INAUDIBLE]
square root [INAUDIBLE].
What's important is
the time difference
for the light traveling
with two legs.
And we find that the time
difference t1 or t2 minus t1
is given by this bit
complicated looking equation.
So now in the experiment, you
want to set up l1 equal to l2.
To simplify, you might not be
able to do it very precisely.
What you can do, however,
is rotate the table.
If you rotate and then
compare the difference
of the differences, you
find that here there's
this v square over
c square dependence.
I used a little trick to
simplify the square root
as I use this 1 plus or
minus x to the nth power.
It's about 1 plus minus
n times x for x plus 1.
And since the
velocity of aether is
presumed to be small compared
to the speed of light,
that's a good approximation.
The result of the experiment
was there was no effect.
They tried-- they
improved the experiment.
They tried to find
smaller effects.
They didn't find any.
The reason for this is
that there is no aether.
But we can use this now to
make a case against the aether.
But you could say
that maybe they
didn't observe anything
because the aether is
dragged with the Earth.
So instead of the Earth
going through this aether,
and therefore, we
experience aether winds,
you could argue
that maybe aether is
localized around the Earth,
moving with the Earth
or maybe moving
with the universe.
And so in the next video,
we'll look at a case
against that scenario as well.